warning fist of awesome contains
gratuitous bear nudity
well then let's continue hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to
fists of awesome this game just came out
on Steam I don't know a damn thing about
it
I just saw the name bought it instantly
no questions asked
I know I'm gonna love this game and I
know you guys are gonna love it too
because you punch bears that's basically
all I saw it I was like yes yes please
Timbers house present-day okie dokie hi
everybody hi everybody I'm so glad you
could make it we're gonna party like
it's 1969 we're gonna chop trees we're
gonna cut down things whoa what's that
noise is it Oh what happened right what
my house my family what wasn't the name
of John Bonzo he's going on I don't know
oh I've been using one hand too much if
you know what I mean
the universe needs you Tim ah
stop shouting ah shut up Kimber listen
to me Earl is Ray's been compromised
everything you know never happened the
timeline must be restored huh why am I
talking my hand not you guys who the
hollow else are you I'm the mighty fist
of awesome that's all I need to know I'm
good
will you have me timber I will I guess
so great I'm taking control oh my god
really really ah oh my god this is weird
I fight bears presents a game by nickel
hunt Nicole hunt she's so awesome I love
this so much I love it already I don't
want to do anything else
good that's working fine now I'm gonna
punch a deer sounds good to me I'm not
gonna argue anything oh my god that is
not a normal deer that is a bit whoa
really
right in the crotch knocked out your
first disgruntled deer your mind is most
malleable I'm not on a present happy
about this more dear
that's what all the people want to know
about God that dear looks creepy for
being pixelated get some is it dead yet
Wow why am I using my feet if I uh
oh you dare do that to me yeah why would
I be using my feet if I got the fist of
awesome it's not the foot of awesome
kick in the balls just walk into my feet
of fury alright there you go
let me just stomp on your crotch a
little bit mom this is too much fun
alright scared the crap out of me you
dick
oh my god nope ah before you even get a
try uh-huh that's it
whoa what did I do that Wow
eat kill love nature in that order in
that specific order
I'm sure if that's what you're trying to
get alright I'm going to eat killing
love some more in nature oh it's a bear
why human Unchained good wagon zoophilia
me keep your paws off me you damn dirty
there I'm gonna get you got him fighting
a bear that's awesome
ah do you dear it's not gonna be a fair
one-on-one fight oh wow Jesus you hurt
bad oh not today that's right
stomp Oh No why you do that come on give
me a chance I'm gonna be fighting bear
there's gonna be a fair fight there's
gonna be a bear fight right in the balls
bear balls don't even think about it
what oh my god what am i I destroyed his
crotch Oh
so dunno how I did that thing I did the
fist fire maybe it was a limited time
use thing yeah that's right
whoa you killed your dear friends hope
oh wow ah no I must get up for my family
I must wait this bear oh god this bear
is kicking my ass
how do I unleash how do I unleash my
fists how am I gonna fist this bear I
really want to fist all the animals in
the woods but I really want to fist this
bear right now just get the fist out get
the fest out shove it Oh God
you son of a [ __ ] no no stay away from
me ya always dead I am the bear killer
gonna kill all the animals kill all the
animals kill him bed kill every animal
now what I'm supposed to do I can't
remember that was it exactly oh here we
go
kill more animals I can that was this a
tutorial that was a hard tutorial or I'm
bad at games no I don't think that could
possibly be true and I'm playing fist of
awesome I need more speed I'm way too
slow what but I'm pressing all of the
buttons I'll enter I needed to press
ENTER Oh
every what's the deal with the crazy
animals I say to my fists the course of
history has been altered many species
have evolved homicidal t'en Nessie's
bears are now the dominant species of
Earth awesome first of all this new
status has given them unbearable egos
good pun good pun guy I appreciate a
good pun maybe they just need a hug a
bear hug Bear Grylls
how many bear puns are we gonna fit in
here can I get a bear counter bear pawn
counter in the bottom corner what the
hell are you a hyena Oh
walk towards stunned enemy to grab what
does that even mean what wait ah s to
kick ah I didn't do that right pan yeah
oh come on
okay grabbing the ball that's how I did
that oh I got it I get it I know how to
fist animals now oh you're gonna love
being fisted by me you're not dead yet
okay looks like you need a bit more out
out out ow ow sassy sue no no don't do
that to me correct Oh
done and done my job here is done
Oh
Oh flailing is not appropriate here come
here
but yeah I'm getting good at this get
the combos up don't don't no no no no no
no don't even think about it oh you want
some too huh how about that little all
of this all of that and a little how do
i okay a little bit little little of
that then a lot of that a lot of that a
little bit of this little a-- right out
skate backwards come on right round em
round house kick Road House
I don't need to crowd control them I
just need to kill them oh that hi any
wood Oh
they've been there the whole time or did
I just scroll them to see that now oh my
god kids hide your eyes no no don't zoom
in on it Barry no oh god don't zoom in
uh no now right there now look at that
face Leo's lips Lena's feet oh that's
weird
I'm going inside uh bear bears I just
threw up in my mouth now that I can't
execute taste I love this game already
yes oh no I want to go in let me in let
me in I want to see stripper bears I
wanna see them bare naked I want to see
the Barenaked Ladies I wanna see yeah
hey I got to come up with more puns I
want them to bear it all for me hope
they let me touch him with my bare hands
ah the weight is unbearable it'll be
like they're barely wearing anything
okay I'm done I'm so so sorry
oh yeah oh that's more like it
that's the stuff now get in boom
check out it yeah I'm killing animals oh
look at that poster I'm famous wanted
timber killing it on site why do the
Bears want to kill it eat me so far
you've punched everyone you've
definitely seen one I've only seen one
bear they started it yeah exactly
not my fault Oh flail are coming in
yeah but storia huh bear bear bear bear
mom give me you give me you you show me
what I did to your friends you wanna
mess with me huh ah no you - you get
stunned you get stunned that feel good
buddy I feel good what about this does I
feel good Oh apparently it does not feel
good hey I'm the winner
I want everything oh no it's not a disco
bear idiom and you loser dribble me no
I'm okay
I'm actually okay I don't want oh what's
the tax oh that's not a fair tax why
would you do that to me it's done
oh oh you don't get stun huh what'd you
do mmm name in a minute
you named him Nick that one's dead now
it's almost dead who you thinking DB oh
not today get your friend oh he's dead
oh not dead II have been man man I'm a
man
Oh hyenas are just gonna keep coming I
can't go out that way
I gotta get you bear don't try to just
go away from me try to moonwalk away
from me your punishment is multiple
punches to the face and groin mmm no no
no no no almost said no can't die he's
almost dead oh okay oh it's like it's
like I don't flailing me
yeah flail your friend you failed
everybody hey I did it I did it good
thank you everybody thank you for
believing in me yeah alright so that was
fists of Awesome it was a pretty fun
game but for 650 I don't know if it's
worth it there's not a lot to the
fighting I would have expected there to
be a bit more you know fisting
destruction capabilities you know if
there was gonna be anything but either
way it was a lot of fun if it's worth it
to you go find it for yourself it's on
Steam fists of awesome Kaena
so thanks again everybody for watching
check out the other awesome games that I
played over in the playlist in the
description right there and as always I
will see you in the next video
Oh
a banner
oh [ __ ] strangle you I'll strangle you